I would love
to play a game.
The name of the game
is "Christian Bale
or Christian Male."
[ organ music playing ]
I'll give you a quote
and you tell me who said it,
either Christian Bale
or a Christian male.
GORBURGER:
Got it?
Mm-hmm.
Uh-huh.
Hey!
You shut up,
little Gorbaby.
Go away.
Ah! Okay, I'm leaving!
Go, or I'll smash you!
ALL:
Aww!
Ugh. All right.
Tig, the first quote...
It sounds like
a Christian male.
That is incorrect!
GORBURGER: It was
Christian Bale as Moses
in Exodus of the Gods
and Kings.
And it didn't do well
internationally
or domestically.
Next quote!
Christian Bale
or a Christian male?
Sounds like
a Christian male.
That is correct!
Next quote.
Who said it?
I-- it has to be
Christian Bale.
That's right!
Oh, Tig, you're
doing wonderfully.
Okay, last one.
It does not sound
very Christian-like.
So...
Christian Bale.
No! That is incorrect!
That was a Christian male
by the name of Mel Gibson.
But you got three
out of four,
which means you win!
I did! What do I--
what do I win?
Yes!
Nothing.
Absolutely nothing.